[Music]
a suspect gets more than he bargained
for when he attempts to hold up a liquor
store where the owner is armed
[Music]
it happened in norco california on july
31st officials say four masked suspects
attempted to rob a liquor store just
before three o'clock in the morning the
suspects were armed with long guns and
had coverings on their faces store
security footage shows a suspect enter
and call for the owner to put his hands
up
that's when the owner pulls out a rifle
of his own and fires
security footage outside the store shows
the suspect run back to a vehicle
yelling he shot my arm off
[Music]
in all the commotion the getaway driver
begins to leave without one of their
passengers
the left behind suspect then jumps into
the vehicle and it drives off officials
say the four suspects were later found
at a hospital one who had injuries
consistent with a shotgun blast
authorities say the vehicle used in the
getaway was stolen as were several
weapons found inside the suspects were
identified as 22 year old justin johnson
27 year old jamar williams and 24 year
old devon broadus so far officials have
not released the name of the suspect who
was wounded for the latest developments
in this case and all things true crime
stay with long crime network i'm sierra
gillespie